[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
Мене обрав замок:
сказав «сюди», і я прийшов.
[Закарпаття, смт. Чинадійово,
замок «Сент-Міклош»]
Я приїхав з-за кордону, де жив довго,
і мені було дуже...
заздрісно,
чому в Угорщині, наприклад, в Словаччині,
Румунії, Німеччині малесеньке село
може щорічно приймати пленери художників,
і туди приїжджають із усього світу.
А у нас, на Закарпатті, один-єдиний,
і то спілчанський, куди запрошують
тільки народних артистів. Чому?
Потім мені спало на думку:
а що, якби оці наші пленери, які ми,
ховаючись по санаторіях,
як якісь останні люди, проводити тут, у замку.
Робити тут також виставки,
і взагалі, щоб на стінах були картини,
щоб відбувались концерти
та зустрічі з письменниками.
Це була така божевільна ідея,
в яку не вірив ніхто,
ні одна людина в цілому світі.
Я теж не вірив.
Але замок вирішив по-іншому,
він сказав: «Бути!», — і почалось.
У цьому приміщенні — етапи відновлення замку.
Зверху дах новий, зроблений нами,
старий мав зовсім інший вигляд.
Він був складений із товстих чотирнадцятиметрових
стропил, то був морений дуб,
який простояв 350 — 400 років
і міг би простояти ще три таких терміни.
Кладку робили з піску, вапна, курячих яєць,
і ще чогось, про що ми не говоримо.
Кладка 16 століття, штукатурка — 17 століття.
Як воно буде — визначить
призначеність цієї кімнати.
Нам би хотілось, щоб тут був зал для концертів камерної класичної музики і зал для шлюбів.
На нашу думку, шлюб, укладений тут,
буде особливим.
Основна тема цього замку на цьому вікні.
Там фігури чоловіка і жінки.
Це говорить про те, що колись тут
зустрілися два великих серця,
які покохали одне одного,
і це кохання визнав цілий світ.
Перші кроки були дуже смішні,
настільки, що ви собі уявити не можете.
Сміялося з мене все село так,
як ні з кого раніше.
Я прийшов у селищну раду
і сказав, що  хотів би цей замок узяти,
щоб зробити там культурно-мистецький центр.
Вони запитали: «Ти що, хлопче?»
«З глузду з'їхав? Ти — художник,
у тебе що, є гроші, ти щось можеш?»
Відповів: «Так щось придумаємо...»
На першому поверсі ми відкрили нашу школу гармонійного розвитку людини,
нашого громадського об'єднання.
Тут є класи з образотворчого мистецтва,
а також музичні і спортивні.
Ми відкрили бібліотеку, разом з паном Юрієм
Андруховичем – він приїжджав до нас.
Усі свої книжки я передав у бібліотеку замку,
а ці нам люди принесли,
проте більшу частину ми купили.
Ось наш раритет з особистою печаткою
графа Шембурна.
Тут є і старіша книжка, з 1800 року, угорського видавництва , ще староугорською написана.
Деякі написані слов'янською мовою,
теж дуже старі книги.
Ось такі наші раритети...
Йосип Бартош вважає, що в Україні
замки і палаци розквітатимуть.
Так!
Так, я так вважаю.
Але за умови, якщо замки і палаци
даватимуть у концесію таким людям,
для яких важлива насамперед ідея.
Люди мають бути ідейні,
які знають, до чого вони ідуть,
котрі дуже добре розуміють суть культури
і для чого вона потрібна,
як із нею тепер бути, за таких умов,
і на що наголошувати.
Дуже мріємо про те, що з'являться,
все ж таки, нові бізнесмени...
Точніше, не нові, а дуже старі, ще старіші, ніж, власне, бізнесмени. Це — меценати.
Наша кінцева мрія...
Ціль, до котрої ми ідемо, —
зробити якомога більше для охоронної зони та створити державний заповідник.
[Оператор
Дмитро Охрименко]
[Монтаж
Микола Носок]
[Музика
Falshback Station-Confession]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]